I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will it all already begun I've
drawn first blood thirsty will be ready
they know we're coming
hey guys Pete here this is going to be
my Game of Thrones season 7 episode 3
trailer breakdown let's do this one
before the recap and review because I
have to make three videos today and this
is the shortest one so if you haven't
watched part two or anything leading up
to this this will spoil what has gone
down episode 3 trailer starts out in
much the same way the San Diego
comic-con 1 did some of the stuff we've
seen but there are some definite gems in
this one so if you want to see a little
bit more there is some stuff that's not
included in this that you can see in my
SDCC trailer breakdown from a couple
days ago so this time we start out the
same way
Daenerys says she was born to rule the
Seven Kingdoms and she will something a
little bit different here though we see
Daenerys from behind on that staircase
we cut to the full shot of all three
dragons circling above Dragonstone and
the SBC trailer we only saw one and we
see the sort of iconic image of her
standing on the stairs again only this
time I think it's cropped a little bit
differently I didn't get a chance to go
back and check but we can actually make
out Jon Snow on the stairs here as far
as I can tell then we go back to seeing
your on arriving at King's Landing it's
the same two shots we saw the small folk
are welcoming he has a victorious look
on his face and we could see that he's
dragging something behind his horse only
this time we know what his gift is
Alaura Yara and tyene are likely with
him and he's bringing them to present to
Cersei then we see Cersei sitting in a
room and she says the war's already
begun I've drawn first blood we see the
landing on Dragonstone again except for
this time we know that this is probably
Jon Snow and Davos who just came down
from white Harbor
we see a shot of Tyrion we haven't seen
before and he says Cersei will be ready
and this is interesting in the context
of what's happened with Yara
they're obviously planning their next
move now that the first one ended
miserably but I mean I'll talk about
this a little bit in a second but you
know they their plan we knew from
episode 2 was the simultaneously attack
Casterly Rock
so not sure if he's talking about that
because we don't really think that she
will be absolutely ready for something
like that anyways we then see this
walking up the path and we can now tell
that it's John and Davos they're
approaching Dragonstone and they are
with Musante and Tyrion who they met on
the shore when I did the last trailer
breakdown I had to kind of hold back a
little bit because we saw a lot of this
stuff and the filming spoilers and you
know I had videos about this so I kind
of knew what was going on but I couldn't
really say because I didn't want to
spoil it for those of you who were
avoiding spoilers like that but yeah now
we know what's happening we saw John Lee
the North he's arrived in the south and
he is heading in to Queens and heiresses
home turf then we get this shot of Dani
she's turning around and what she has to
be looking at here is Jon Snow if the
other scene you know we see Jon in the
in the stairs he's come down and what's
important about this is this is their
first face-to-face meeting without any
advisors or anybody else like this is
just them one on one we're going to see
in a little bit when he's first formally
presented to her in the throne room but
this is probably after and it's probably
a little bit more intense because
there's nobody else around we see great
worm putting on his helmet was what
remains of her fleet at this point I
mean at the end of that battle is see it
looks like not much remained of what you
are and Theon had so this is a pretty
key moment in the entire campaign if you
think about it we see Jaime and we've
seen this scene before and I still a
hundred percent in the way that it looks
here it looks like he's probably coming
out to greet you're on
this is probably at King's Landing but
it's not a hundred percent clear we see
that shot of your on taking a bow in
front of the Queen that we saw on the
other trailer for SDCC we cut back to
Sansa walking away from the heart tree
which we've seen in a couple of trailers
at this point this has a little bit more
context now that we know that
Littlefinger sort of steps to John to I
guess you would say work together and
John choked them out so now that John's
gone we have to imagine that little
fingers in full speed ahead mode and as
far as trying to take songs away from
her family we get that shot of the
unsullied storming in at Casterly Rock
we got confirmation that that is where
they were headed in episode 2 we see
grey worm going into the water to enter
that passage I talked about this in one
of the other videos you know they tease
that sort of passage and we know Tyrion
is a when he was at the rock he was in
charge of the sewers so he probably had
some secret passageways for his [ __ ]
and whatnot and he gives this
information the grey worm so they can
come in and we've seen them open the
doors for the rest of their forces in
other trailers as well see a couple
shots of the battle we have nothing new
though we've seen those before and then
we see the big stuff the stuff that we
hadn't seen any other trailers before we
knew that John was definitely headed
there we see him being led into the
throne room but look on his face is
pretty much of all whenever he looks
upon Daenerys who's sitting there on her
throne the music's a nice set up
everything is pretty high-quality as far
as you know it's a pretty badass trailer
scene I don't think anyone would
disagree with me there and that is where
we end it so because they let they did
put the other trailer out the other day
there's not a lot of stuff new here but
at least now that we've seen episode 2
we know that there's no doubt that John
will arrive at Dragonstone in episode 3
it kind of seemed to make a lot of sense
based on the fact that we know he's
going back north and all that because
we've seen them in a lot of
north of the wall and the trailers but
now we know for sure now that he's
gotten the Raven from Tyrion he's laid
it all out he's left Sansa back at home
to take care of things little fingers
there to scheme hopefully the other
northerners will be able to make
everything work I mean I don't know how
that's all going to play out this is big
news right I mean all of us who have
been following spoilers knew that all
this stuff was going to happen and I
imagine everybody else guessed it was
going to happen but this is the first
interior shots we've seen of John and
Davos inside the throne room and for two
characters that have never had a scene
together this is going to be pretty big
I mean it's pretty freakin exciting not
to mention whenever they're approaching
and maybe in the second meeting whenever
he's talking to Daenerys I mean this is
all going to go down in the next episode
and we get a little tease of the Dragons
there so we have to kind of expect that
John's going to meet those dragons as
well now if I had to guess I would say
John will be there for a bit I don't
know about Melisandre how she fits into
this Davos obviously wants to kill her
on sight but we've seen that Daenerys is
likely going to offer her protection so
definitely a cool trailer one thing
that's noteworthy about this trailer
though is the things that we didn't see
didn't get any Arya didn't get any brand
like we figure brain is just not going
to enter the wall and then be at Castle
black and there'll be nothing with him
but we don't see any clips in any of
these trailers so far with him he's got
to get moving because he's got to get
back to Winterfell before too long we
also don't see any Samwell orange aura
which they were right in the middle of a
pretty serious procedure to cure his
greyscale so you know I don't know why
they're not really showing that if
they're just really trying to pump up
the anticipation for urine and Cersei
and then John and De Niro
so I mean those are obviously the big
points outside of Casterly Rock being
attacked I mean you're ket you're
attacking the Lannisters at their
stronghold you know it's a big deal it's
definitely a big deal let me know what
you think I'm going to get busy on my
recap now so I'm going to finish this
off please like the video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel I'm
doing a heavy schedule Game of Thrones
all throughout the season just like I
did last year when they were filming
follow me on Twitter and on my other
social media accounts to get in touch
with me and most of all thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon
I was born to rule the Seven Kingdoms
and I will the rules already begun are
gone first blood thirsty blue be ready
they know we're coming